the jurogan experience let's take it
back to the day that this happened
you're you're 22 you're logging you're
you're in the woods
tell me what happened well uh it's just
uh
you know when you're done working the
hard physical labor everybody's kind of
jacked up and there was a whole lot of
chatter in the car we're just talking
away you know it's starting to get dark
we
just loaded up our equipment we're
headed out and i looked up ahead and i
saw
this kind of glow coming through the
trees first i thought
no big deal you know what we'd it was
dare hunting season
uh thought maybe there was some hunters
camped up down the hill up there
maybe light shining into a tent it was
still something really strange kind of
caught my eye and uh
one by one the other guys in the crew
started looking but nobody said oh my
god what's that or anything like that it
was just
kind of an idle curiosity at first but
when we
burst into the clearing where we could
see the source of this
glow uh it was just
whoa you know i mean it was just
mind-blowing instantly
uh
i i inexplicably
got out of the truck and ran toward this
thing
but uh i thought i thought it was just
gonna uh take off
be gone in a flash and so when you say
in the clearing so you're
are you driving on a dirt road yeah it's
a dirt road trees are real thick this
was a part of the contract we hadn't cut
in yet
so um trees were a lot thicker there
except for this clearing and
we weren't the only ones that's hot we
found out later
sheriff had on file uh people who were
in the area that saw it you know
hunters and fishermen over there at
black canyon lake
and the movement that
they described was what the crew
described when it left
and of course i didn't see that but what
what what did
they describe they described uh this
glow rising up
and streaking off i believe they said
toward the northeast
and there were some people that
probably don't want to be public about
it but there was one guy who was
just deer hunting and he
worked in military intelligence and uh
uh he stuck by what he and his wife saw
they were both uh together and uh
another guy that was at black canyon
lake uh
i won't mention any of those guys names
unless they uh
joe's do but uh um
found out later that there was
more uh official investigation that
nobody talked about at the time um
immediately though this was all nonsense
and these guys murdered him and uh
even my oldest brother he he didn't
believe me he thought they had killed me
what we were doing with the the brush
that we cut was
piling it up there were piles that were
in the clearing
so that the forest service could burn
these piles uh
you know when the conditions were right
where it wouldn't spread you know
wet conditions otherwise but burn up
this excess
material to reduce the fire danger in
the woods
and my oldest brother was tearing those
piles apart he was
certain that my body was under under
there
and there were some pretty um
testy confrontations between him and my
brother
and i think even my uh other brother
dwayne he
initially took that approach but
he quickly became sure that they
were telling the truth now you
what do you remember when you're going
through your mind
and you're trying this is a story you've
told so many times
and this is a story that's been turned
into a film which it's got to be very
surreal
but when you look into your memories and
you try to
go back to that day well i don't try it
it's something i try to block out but uh
it's unforgettable and there's uh what
do you remember seeing when you ran into
the clearing
well um the whole clearing was lit up
with this
weird glow uh it's really hard
to uh for any artist or movie
to try to duplicate the the strange
glow there was there made everything
uh look really really pretty eerie you
know
and uh uh
i could have a color to it um
it was kind of a golden color
but with a kind of a softness to it that
was
it wasn't like uh beams of light
shooting out it was just this um
haze of of of light and did it seem to
come from a specific
part of the craft or most of the surface
seemed to be glowing there were darker
areas that didn't uh give off light but
uh
uh it was uh the parts
weren't glowing it wasn't so hard uh
right that
that you couldn't look at it
but it uh had a metallic look to it
so what did the craft itself look like
it was
um a
classic disc shaped uh craft um
the uh years later uh
um there was a report
uh i can never remember names but this
guy
was saying that uh he worked at area 51
and they had something in there
he worked with the tester model uh
corporation
to create a model of what he was
describing
and that that's actually the closest of
any of the other descriptions i've seen
but i don't think
i don't think these things have just one
type of craft i think there's many many
different shapes
what makes you think that well personal
experience
i try not to emphasize these other
incidents but
i've seen the
glowing sphere i've seen the
giant black triangle um
um
other other craft that were
a ball of light that you couldn't
penetrate the light with your eyes
but uh now this is after this experience
um
i think the reason my brother dwayne was
persuaded more quickly than my brother
dawn
was that he saw a craft
in those woods i was probably 10 miles
from there
while deer hunting and
uh it was kind of tic-tac-shaped and
that's a something that's uh
been observed by you know in military
reports recently
yeah so you see this thing this
uh this disc shaped craft
and then what happens um
it started to move and started to get
louder
louder yeah it was the guys in the truck
heard it too
uh there was a low uh
uh thunderous kind of a rumble
that you actually sort of
felt more than heard
and then there were other high high
pitched
frequencies i was talking to a group of
students from a technical college and
they were really interested in what the
sound was like to try to
you know compare that with the theories
that they
had concerning what might be their
propulsion
but
the increase in volume it suddenly
got louder as it started to move and
you know at the same time the guys in
the truck were screaming get away from
there you know
let's go let's go get back in the truck
let's go and uh
which would have been the smart thing to
do but as soon as it moved
it startled me and i just ducked for
cover
there was a log there i got down behind
this log
and they were screaming let's go let's
go let's go
and uh i uh
didn't need to be told i was just gonna
you know stand up and run away
but see when i when i jump for cover i i
i went down and forward to reach where
the log would hide me
and that brought me closer to it
so when i stood up at that point that
was the closest
i was to the object how close uh
i it was still like eight or ten feet
away you know
from the surface of it but that was when
the energy discharge happened
i've worked on a number of theories
about what might have happened at the
time
some of the other guys on the truck were
thinking uh
i mean immediately steve said it got him
like you know
if you shot a deer you got it you know
and so
uh it might not not have been
as we assumed at first that it was some
kind of stun gun or something but
uh maybe just
closing that gap uh allowed this energy
to leap to ground through me
and uh like static electricity or
something yeah one thing that really
uh weighs heavy in that direction is
um that when uh i found
years later that the
they they have satellites or something
that record the number of lightning
strikes
and that area has the highest frequency
of lightning strikes
of any place in the continental united
states
except for the everglades the everglades
has a bit more but that's over water
so that adds to another theory what were
they doing there
you know so that area
that has a high level of lightning
strikes
do you think it makes sense that they're
observing that or is that
is that why they were there do you have
any thoughts about that
well uh until up until a few years ago
you know you walk down the rim road and
if you see a tree that's been hit by
lightning
you can always see it it's a strip of
bark that's just blasted out of there
and it's all
bare and it can actually still survive
the lightning strike but it turns the
the sap to steam instantly and it just
explodes out the side of the
uh tree blows the bark off but um
i was at a conference where this lady
was i say what's this and she says
that's folky right
i said what what's that and she says
that's when lightning
strikes the earth you've got millions of
volts millions of degrees that form
these crystals
that aren't formed geologically so
i kind of leaned towards this theory
that perhaps they were looking for folk
right
for a very unique kind of crystal
uh that would be formed by uh that kind
of
blast of energy i'd never heard of folky
right before
hmm can you pull up an image of that
jamie i'd like to see what that looks
like
i know um tritonite is something that
happens when uh
it's they call it nuclear glass it
happens when there is
uh either a nuclear explosion or uh
whether when uh asteroid impacts hit the
earth
that's it right there well these
crystals are supposed to have very
special properties for people into
crystal
stuff but uh what does that say there
jamie this is what happens
that's what wow that's wild
it's beautiful yeah it really is that's
pretty wild
so you might it might be that they were
looking for that
maybe something that they use for energy
what is that
that's really when lightning struck
santa created that thing that's wild
that is wild look at that it looks like
a tree coming out of the sand
uh i'd say yes that was wet sand yeah
but
yeah well it's right next to the beach
it must be wet that is crazy
that's really wild man catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience